the biggest presidential debate ever
exposed sharp divisions among the
Democratic presidential hopefuls his
candidates took aim at the newest
frontrunner it often seemed like it was
11 against 1 senator Elizabeth Warren
the fastest-rising candidate in the
polls faced most of the questions from
the other contenders on the stage last
night
Warren's opponents challenged her on
everything from her health care plan to
her proposed tax on wealth they also had
a lot to say about President Trump ed
O'Keefe is outside the debate site in
Westerville Ohio and what struck you
last night
well good morning Anthony it was the
fourth round of debates in the twenty
mccr attic presidential primary but the
first set against the backdrop of
impeachment and on that issue there was
near universal agreement Donald Trump
needs to be held accountable Trump is
the most corrupt president in the
history of this country I started the
need to impeach movement all 12
candidates in agreement on one topic
impeaching President Trump I swore an
oath to do my job as a senator do my
duty this president has violated his I
will do mine and former Vice President
Joe Biden tried once again to move the
discussion away from his son Hunter and
his work in Ukraine my son did nothing
wrong
I did nothing wrong but it was
Massachusetts senator Elizabeth Warren
who has been rising in the polls and
became a new target sometimes I think
that Senator Warren is is more focused
on being punitive or or pitting some
part of the country against the other
she was hit on her plan for a wealth tax
the problem is that it's been tried in
Germany France Denmark Sweden and all
those countries ended up repealing it
and for once again refusing to say
whether her health care plan would raise
taxes on the middle class
your signature senator is to have a plan
for everything except this Medicare for
all is the gold standard we can pay for
this I've laid out the basic principles
costs are going to go up for the wealthy
they're going to go up for big
corporations they will not go up for
middle-class families at the end of the
day the overwhelming majority of people
will save money on their health care
bills but I do think it
is appropriate to acknowledge that taxes
will go up at least Bernie's being
honest here and saying how he's going to
pay for this and that taxes are gonna go
up and I'm sorry Elizabeth but you have
not said that everyone also agreed the
president's troop withdrawal from Syria
was a mistake we have an erratic crazy
president who knows not a damn thing
about foreign policy think about how
absurd it is that this president is
caging kids on the border in effectively
letting Isis prisoners run free but they
disagreed over how long US troops remain
you would continue to support having US
troops in Syria for an indefinite period
of time you can put an end to endless
war without embracing Donald Trump where
is the question what we are doing or
what we were doing in Syria was keeping
our word meanwhile the night ended with
big news for Bernie Sanders who were in
the endorsement of two well-known
liberals Minnesota congresswoman Ilhan
Omar announced that she's backing his
presidential bid and CBS News has
learned that New York congresswoman
Alexandria Ocasio Cortes is set to
endorse Sanders on Saturday that's a big
get for him given that she has a wide
national following and was also hotly
pursued by Senator Warren Anthony Edie
thank you